one of the most high-profile Republican
lawmakers on Capitol Hill is getting out
of politics South Carolina congressman
trey Gowdy who is a former federal
prosecutor says he is returning to the
justice system chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel tells us
tonight gaudi's announcement comes amid
partisan warfare with no end in sight
and a midterm election looming I call
upon all of us to set aside our
differences Republican leaders hope
president Trump's effort to reach across
the aisle would lead to lawmakers
finding areas of cooperation but top
House Democrats are not changing their
tune unfortunately one evening speech
doesn't erase a conflict ridden chaotic
year that has driven our country even
further apart GOP leaders are facing a
wave of retirements with news that House
Oversight Chairman trey Gowdy intends to
retire after this term Gowdy is one of
nine House committee chairs announcing
they won't seek reelection so their
focuses on getting things done not the
rigors of a campaign Republican
lawmakers intend to set the agenda for
the rest of 2018 trying to leave unified
on what can be accomplished we will be
spending the extended time around the
infrastructure question workforce
development as well as the budget
process itself
one area expected to attract democrat
support is on rebuilding the nation's
crumbling infrastructure we've been
through so many other battles that we
haven't had the time to get into the
details on infrastructure hopefully we
get the ability to start putting the
real meat on the bone but the House
Democrat leader mocked the president's
proposal the president presents himself
the man of big ideas and then he
presents a lame puny infrastructure
channel proposal funding deadlines next
week and a daca deadline in early March
a key Senate Republican says it's time
for Democrats to get serious we have to
do something on the border and we want
to make sure that on March 5th or
whenever we don't have 600 and 600
70,000 people that are in school are
currently employed lose their work
status adding to the deadline pressure
the Congressional Budget Office said
late today lawmakers would likely need
to raise the debt ceiling in early March
the previous estimate was Congress had
until late March or early April
Brett my command will live on the hill
Mike thanks